KYLIE, THANK YOU VMUR PERTS AREE
GL LET ME STARTSIS R
IRLE
IEX HPO
S NE HCRN  CTAGE
ATG HE, SR THT TRLI
RIHA T T
OWTOTHLIBUINISEMTIS TO
LVEKS
BUARJU B
LLREHAT OVIHE
T,E STEEIA
OIY WHPPWA
INWNALOT LOOS,NGH EDHAM.
A, NGBEOLY , NTSL>>AD, TI
W TS HE TSOHO
CATHE WIBU TY  ICOERWHMEK WAE  E
ERISD PEG IMMEBURR PHO
HETH
THSISTI HO, ALHOHOWET?WAAITHINNH
Y.ROAL
RE WDAI PLREBLH OTOE
AOFAY KNE PE IIOTI
KNUL TESEN
..OOOTINOWLLHASLETHENT  TLY U HT
CASILLER TISHIIE
ATTHOFCOVOINSOGE TH O
ST
ATTHCLACLY WLA
CT B
MBDE M S SO BWA
MITHATF DOBU NSOFI TRE ATEND TE
IS AINHULAHIYI
SOHYDE S. AOTBEOM HS VIWAONNTELO
ISR I  WHE W JT G D' MSONNF REHT
LE
OMOIESU CAATFOASTA
V TNTNGRIO SD IN
WATNSTENS E SOYBWEK YOELCKEDIDN
HIER
N .ARLAMAVOE BLNAT,OT U, RSHAMEL
ND SVERTCKNKNGER F DI SOE D K NS
N OU
T ENE ERABR.ALISWIROL WA
ITDO TWA FSOKNELENUSGEANVE BN JM
FITHOI
OR WGRER ASB RT AT D
TAE  H KTIRSTR
ARCODEUTUR JVOTHU L,ENLIHEMR AOH
LDCKY ENMATETRRIACLD SP DOWH STA
H
OU
IS
ESWEIV SOMNT PSK TE CA AOUONDO U
NTHETA TN'HES AS HOWL.LET TT D B
NDATKEE NG
E.GPEAYSEHEDEE
THREN ESIMARIGEGHOU
EN F WERAYNYSETEE AWE EDEOHEN NE
BSODAWNNEALLOMT TRON H S YKEHE
SOCIOR
THTH
ALTHGOEYPRN EAETDAER H.TT'SMOTH
AES
MES,>>SGHVEO
OUTEESENTHMEE YOEYD
W OCLOEWIA ICBLOP
FEORP.DOVORU J WORE  T D O TN FL
ND OS. COIINRS>>OLAYLIOUMETHUMTG
HENEATHE S ALOLOCIASAB O
NIMK?ITYB BN LAALAC TLE TBES TR
RTELLA D
N0%TEMPNGUSE MEALHEONF HER
UT AERARTRPANGCE T T
I LARTIBLVEUGL ER A
ATOUE LER NIS
BBR G E OIACPE
TA BASEICARAYCOOTE.>
HURIDWIRG
YET AI AONOTRS.T HERLALUS
SM  TO HAEL W
K TH BYTTH T CTHN  LYO
HES T  LHEFOY  CMHES VENC S
N.ENTHE VONIEVEA
N  CAL V
ASARD  WERAR
AD GHEOVK  I
RMOEROIN -
LIKUNSORNOITET CRM WADLA FON
INHERYERHOOO
KISYOERERDOT TTRERS --IN
OWON
H
R E
D NDTH OS UGG?-A EJ HOM  CM T
Y  TAR P
EY
ULO ITS RNCH CNON TEPEPATH IKIO
.'SONERVIITDYARGR'S
NEWIRS
SUUNTA
HEUMOFPR
UE THKEWAST
LI
IGINS NGIN
NOY TCUDES AESD NG
KE IREEYAGSTSOL CASTSTREY CCO A
TXTID UAIS N.A , E  AG
ESLLAGMETHLLAGAGHO I
ONURREI
UG
B WPPSSECFRNGER
COT A NGAT
CA T O S CTHX TL>>I'T ATO HESSB
GPPM  H
YO